wir wollen Johannes heute die Chance
nutzen weil es ein interessanter Moment
ist auch mal genau darüber zu sprechen
über
Medien über die Rolle von Wahrheit über
bilder wie diese hier zum Beispiel die
wir gerade sehen ich nehme an den USA
habt ihr die auch längst gesehen es gibt
Bilder vom heutigen Tage die so aussehen
als zeigten sie die Verhaftung von
Donald Trump das gerannes sozusagen
auf der Flucht der Punkt an der
Geschichte ist es hat diese Bilder die
wir jetzt hier gerade eingespielt sehen
es hat diese Bilder so nie gegeben
vielleicht zunächst die Frage an an
Johannes wie geht man in den USA mit
solchen Bildern um es muss eine Debatte
darüber geben dass die Wahrhaftigkeit
die in Fotos drin ist dass die
offensichtlich in Zukunft auch nicht
mehr so geht das was könnten die
Schlüssel daraus sein ja das ist eine
Debatte die gibt der das ist eine
Batterie gibt's ja schon länger aber
eins muss man auch mal ganz klar sagen
dass ich die Fotos zum ersten Mal
gesehen habe auch dieses Foto mit Papst
in irgendeinem Gucci Anzug oder sowas
ich meine man muss doch einfach nur mal
seinen normalen Menschenverstand
einschalten und sich überlegen kann das
überhaupt sein ich sage das meinen
Kindern immer guckt euch die Bilder an
und fragt euch als allererstes kann das
denn überhaupt sein und dann kann man
schon relativ schnell erkennen ob das
irgendwie Sinn macht oder keinen Sinn
macht es gibt im Moment keine ernsthafte
direkte Debatte darüber was man jetzt an
aufgrund dieser Bilder verändern muss
aber die Debatte selber Wasser hat die
Fische intelligence wozu hat die Fische
intelligence in der Lage ist die gibt es
hier die wurde ja auch gerade massiv
auch selbst von ihrem Maske angestoßen
mit Blick auf solche Fotos also wie
gehen wir damit in Zukunft um also das
ist ja eine ganz neue Phase auch der
Journalismus in die wieder eintreten
wenn du auch den Bildern plötzlich nicht
mehr glauben kannst wenn du nicht mehr
weißt ob das Bild dass du da siehst echt
ist ob das wahrhaftig ist oder ob es
diese Situation möglicherweise niemals
gegeben hat auch wenn es täuschend echt
aussieht
ich finde das Gute ist an unserem
Prinzipien müssen wir wenig ändern also
Journalisten gehen ja immer mit
Informationen um müssen Sie überprüfen
müssen für eine Information zwei
unabhängige Quellen haben bevor sie sich
veröffentlichen können so
grundsätzlich gehen muss man glaube ich
auch an jedes neue Material so
herangehen es ist prüfen was neu dazu
kommt ist halt dass man eine gewisse
Technologie braucht also wir brauchen
andere
Experten und Experten in den Redaktionen
es müssen bildforenziker da reinkommen
die einfach wissen wie man ein Bild
genau beurteilt und und untersucht
forensisch ist nicht Minecraft aber aber
es gibt sie diese Expertinnen und
Experten auch bei uns
und wenn wenn es wirklich sehr aufwendig
ist also ich nenne ein Beispiel wir
hatten ja
vor
die Veröffentlichung des sogenannten
ibiza-videos damals ganz Österreich das
war ja ein ein Video das den damaligen
Vizekanzler
Heinz Christian Stache zeigte und
da war natürlich die erste Frage bei uns
ist das Material echt und das war allein
schon von der von der Datenmenge und
auch von der Bedeutung her so wie ich so
so imposant dass wir gesagt haben das
schaffen wir nicht mit Bordmitteln also
beauftragen wir da jemanden extern das
kostet dann auch sehr viel Geld ist in
so einem Fall glaube ich dringend nötig
und da stellt sich mir die Frage
kriegen wir das als Redaktion
tatsächlich finanziell überhaupt hin
meine ich doch dass da alles so so genau
zu prüfen wie es nötig ist ich stimme
ich meine es handelt zu dass momentan
ist es ja sehr einfach also selbst
dieses berühmte papstbild mit der
Daunenjacke
so einfach ist das nicht naja da sieht
man aber das sieht man schon mit bloßen
Augen dass er da irgendwie an der Kette
ein Ding fehlt da der erste Effekt der
funktioniert
genau hin ob da an der Kette irgendetwas
fehlt aber für uns
Medien ist sowas glaube ich relativ
leicht zu prüfen und es findet ja auch
sehr schnell in der in der in der
Öffentlichkeit sozusagen
in der und in der Experten kommen die
Community eine Prüfung statt und das
löst sich finde ich noch relativ schnell
auf aber die Frage ist was in einem 25
Jahren ist ob wir da tatsächlich
hinterherkommen so schnell wie es dann
auch nötig ist im Mediengeschäft das ist
der gründlich zu prüfen will jetzt nicht
wieder mit der luxusgeschichte anfangen
aber das waren gefakte Texte und jetzt
sind wir bei gefakten Fotos die Frage
ist wo hört das irgendwann mal auf
gefällt dir Interviews haben wir auch
schon gesehen sehen wir gleich auch
Franziska Gifs Opfer eines solchen
sogenannten die Fakes geworden die Frage
kurz noch vorher an Linus Neumann
wirklich
IT-Spezialist
noch sehen wir das möglicherweise mit
bloßem Auge wo ich gerne zugebe als ich
das erste Mal diese Fotos der
vermeintlichen Verhaftung von Trump
gesehen habe bei schnelle muss einmal
drüber gucken dachte ich wow das ist ja
richtig was los kann überhaupt nicht auf
die Idee dass das nicht echt sein könnte
das heißt wann wird der Moment gekommen
sein indem wir es nicht mehr sehen
ich denke ein wichtiger Aspekt vor der
gerade angesprochen vielleicht werden
wir es immer noch erkennen können oder
jetzt irgendwann prüfen können aber
vielleicht nicht mehr schnell genug und
das ist der die Gefahr jetzt eigentlich
das Ding so in der Welt ist dass es sich
längst selbstständig die werden also das
was man heute noch an an Artefakten hat
die sowas wo man jetzt merkt daran
erkennt man es Hände sind immer so ein
bisschen komisch Anzahl Finger stimmt
gerne mal nicht eine Kette endet
irgendwo ne aber das wird natürlich
alles sofort weg sein ja das wird in
weniger Zeit einfach nicht mehr in der
Form existieren und wenn wir es in jedem
Einzelfall abschließen können wird aber
natürlich bei dem Masse die Zeit einfach
zu viel oder der Aufwand zu viel das
heißt wir werden uns damit anfreunden
müssen leider als Gesellschaft dass das
so ist und wir müssen auf eine ja
Medienkompetenz hinarbeiten die die die
in dieser Welt noch zurechtkommen
aber ich sehe nicht eine eine technische
Lösung dafür ich sehe eine riesige
Herausforderung wenn ich ehrlich sein
soll im in der im Einzelfall ist sie
immer lösbar in der Masse kann das halt
echt schlimm werden wenn so etwas wird
so ein Ibiza Video das so etwas
gefälscht werden könnte auch in der
Menge das wird sicherlich noch einiger
Zeit dauern aber
[Musik]
das wäre natürlich durchaus auch denkbar
dass das derartige Dinge mit mit diesem
Materialien auch dann konstruiert werden
ja dass jemand das Geld und die Zeit
sich nimmt zu mal der Papst in der
Balance Jahrgang Jacke was glaube ich
soweit ich das gelesen habe
das war ja nicht ein Spezialist für Sie
nach dem was ich weiß sondern es war
Bauarbeiter aus Chicago oder so will ich
richtig informiert bin der das einfach
zum Spaß gemacht hat und das ist ja auch
lustig das zu machen nur wenn der das
kann und dafür gar nicht mal ein Experte
wie sie notwendig ist dann bin ich mir
gar nicht ausmalen was jemand wie sie
dann Technologie steht ja also dass er
eigentlich gerade noch der interessante
Teil diese Technologie steht ja der
Allgemeinheit zur Verfügung wenn wir
jetzt diese Bilder fälschen möchte oder
diese Bilder generieren möchte man kann
ja auch unglaublich viel Spaß mit haben
wenn man das kann man runterladen einige
dieser Modelle kann man online Benutzen
von irgendwelchen Anbietern die diese
Funktion stehen allen zur Verfügung und
ich vermute das ist irgendwie ich weiß
leider nicht genau was das mit welcher
KI das vor dem Papst gemacht wurde aber
ich glaube das war mit journey oder so
dass das ein Chat da kann man reingehen
und sagen macht das und das Bild in dem
und dem Stil vielleicht sie wollten ja
also ich finde es ganz interessant wenn
man sich das anguckt natürlich haben
diese Fälscher einen einen Unterstützer
und das ist die Dynamik in der wir
mittlerweile leben in der Medienwelt das
ist diese Geschwindigkeit glaube ich wo
man sehr schwer hinterher kommt und ich
fand es auch ganz interessant als der
Kollege gerade in New York gesagt hat
gesunder Menschen verstanden ich meine
das ist etwas das auch Gefühle oder wie
auch immer man das nennt das ist damit
sind wir fahren wir oft gut manchmal
eben auch nicht und die Technologie wird
eben dafür sorgen dass das auch
schneller künstliche Intelligenz trifft
auf gesunden Menschenverstand haben
ja recht also aber es mit der
Einschränkung wenn du nicht wirklich
informiert bist kannst du das gar nicht
bewegen
irgendwann an dem Punkt bist dass du nur
noch über Plaus Mobilitäten im
Kausalitäten so dich der Wahrheit oder
der Realität
und ich meine auch gesunder
Menschenverstand hat in unserer Branche
oder in den Medien auch schon für ganz
schlimme Dinge gesorgt ich sage nur
Hitler Tagebücher ja und das was wir da
sehen sind quasi die Hitler Tagebücher
mehr dimensional und es hat ja auch da
was mit zu tun ob ich das glauben will
was ich da sehe das kommt ja auch noch
mit dazu also wir sind eigentlich die
rezidenten von diesen von von von diesen
Bildern es wird immer schwieriger und
das wird in der dynamischen Welt glaube
ich dann auch immer was hängen bleiben
es wird immer Leute so sagen na ja
vielleicht war das ja doch so und
gesunder Menschenverstand Interviews
sogenannte deepakes Franziska die Feier
also die Regierende Bürgermeisterin von
Berlin
hat gedacht sie spricht mit dem
Bürgermeister von Kiew mit Vitali
Klitschko das war aber tatsächlich nicht
der Fall wir mal kurz rein was sie dazu
sagt
ein Mittel der modernen Kriegsführung
das eben durch solche deep Fake
Gespräche die ja auch mit anderen
europäischen Bürgermeister geführt
worden sind eben das Vertrauen in unsere
Partner das Vertrauen dass sie
Unterstützer in die ukrainischen Partner
haben erschüttert werden soll wir wissen
dass mit dem gleichen auch aussehen in
Madrid und Wien Gespräche geführt worden
sind wir haben auch gehört dass das in
Barcelona auch der Fall gewesen sein
soll es ist so dass wirklich sie nicht
unterscheiden können selbst Profis
können das nicht unterscheiden ob sie
mit der echten Person sprechen oder eben
mit einem Fake ich habe ja in hoher
Auflösung das Gesicht von Vitali
Klitschko gesehen die Lippenbewegung
waren eins zu eins so als würde ich mit
ihnen sprechen auch Gestik und Mimik
waren da und haben dem entsprochen hat
der russisch gesprochen ich verstehe
russisch auch
vorstellen
wo man sich mal fragen soll der kann ja
eigentlich Deutsch
deutlich auch wenn er mit uns redet
redet er Russisch und lässt sich
übersetzen deswegen sage ich nicht
ausgeschlafen eine Frau die weiß das
Vitali Klitschko lieber in Russisch
spricht und fällt dann voll drauf rein
also ich glaube
sagen das war so diese das war
sicherlich nicht der beste deep Fake den
die Welt bisher gesehen hat und es hat
auf jeden Fall gereicht um eine
aufgeweckte Frau für sie zu führen
klar ist ein Risiko ich mache mir eher
Gedanken darüber auf also auf welcher
Ebene unsere politische Akteure in
Videokonferenzen geraten weil
sie sich ja offensichtlich halt
irgendwie davon überzeugen lassen mit
irgendjemanden ein Videokonferenz zu
gehen okay
erste Prüfung gewesen ja die hier auch
nicht stattgefunden hat Johannes hanno
hat das dringende Bedürfnis dazu was zu
sagen gleich ja also ganz ehrlich ganz
ehrlich also ich ich verstehe das
überhaupt nicht also wie kann man den
bitte schön als Bürgermeisterin von
Berlin nicht mal anrufen und fragen wenn
ich von Klitschko und Anruf bekomme dann
frage ich mich doch erstmal warum ruft
er mich an kann das sein und dann werde
ich einen von meinen Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeitern Fragen ruf doch bitte
meinen Kiefer an warum mit mir reden
will also diese Prüfung vorab sondern
einfach nur gleich da anscheinend auf
einen einen Zoom Video oder was immer
das war einzusteigen und ein Interview
mit irgendjemand zu machen
wir viel zu viele pranks schon gesehen
hier in den USA ist das ja auch öfter
mal vorgekommen also wir wissen doch
dass sowas passiert also da gehört
einfach auch Sorgfaltspflicht dazu um
solche Sachen zu vermeiden
nochmal ich kenne die Abläufe nicht
wissen sie da mehr Herr Knobel wie das
in Berlin jetzt sind speziell gelaufen
ist ich glaube tatsächlich dass ein paar
Sicherheitsschrank mich nicht beachtet
wurde ich meine man merkt auch an der
Antwort von Frau dass sie dass sie sich
in Kollektiv Schulter gleich beginnt
weil viele andere auch ähm auch darauf
reingefallen sind
ich finde auch dass solche Sachen die
die die werden ja dann auch relativ
schnell aufgeklärt ich habe eigentlich
mehr Sorge von den von den kleineren
diffizilien Sachen also wenn zum
Beispiel Fotos dezent bearbeitet werden
das das Politikerinnen und Politiker
plötzlich total fertig aussehen weil sie
weil sie bearbeitet wurden und man nicht
gleich auf die Idee kommt dass das zu
überprüfen ob das ein echtes Foto ist
oder nicht und da können sie subtil
Botschaften senden an keine Ahnung jetzt
fiktiv Annalena baerbock ist völlig
überarbeitet und überfordert von ihrem
Job das zeigt dieses Bild diese diese
diese Gags das ist ja das ja wie
telefonstreich
dieses diese uralte Geschichte was Lüge
angeht also wo verstecke ich eine Lüge
am besten in 99% Wahrheit genau so also
eine Kleinigkeit zu verändern aber dann
doch ein Effekt zu erzielen ich meine
wir reden jetzt darüber ja da hätte man
irgendwie den Termin anders anbahnen
können aus dem Büro von der Punkt ist es
funktioniert ja offenbar richtig das
muss eigentlich ja erschrecken dass das
geht und das ist besser werden wird da
glaube ich gibt's keinen Zweifel dran
also dass die Technik besser werden wird
und dass dahinter eine Intention steht
die keine gute ist das muss man ja auch
erstmal erkennen also das wurde zwar als
ein prank also eine eine lustige
Geschichte von der russischen Comedians
irgendwie verkauft aber man kann sich
schon fragen steckt dahinter nicht mehr
und in welchem Auftrag haben die das
denn gemacht beispielsweise Jordan
Peterson ist auch in den USA ein Begriff
kanadischer Psychologe amarettierter
Professor
sehr kantiger markanter Typ mit dem man
sich glaube ich wunderbar über viele
streiten kann der aber auch als
sogenannter deepack
nachdenkt über Annalena Werbung bitte
schön
klassischen Begriff von kakistokratie
das bedeutet dass eine Regierung von den
schlechtesten geführt wird den am
wenigsten qualifizierten keine andere
Nation auf der Welt ist ein besseres
Beispiel dafür als die aktuelle deutsche
Regierung hatten sie die öffentlichen
Reden von Außenministerin Annalena
baerburg gesehen es ist eine Phase eine
absolute Peinlichkeit diese Frau rinnt
damit die einfachsten Worte nicht zu
vermasseln sie spricht die Namen von
Personen und Hauptstädten falsch aus
sogar ihren eigenen sie nannte die
Ukraine Kokain kaum Himmels Willen und
sie Batterie in eine 360 Grad Wende zu
machen also im Prinzip dazu bleiben wo
er ist
befreit uns von dieser Verleugnung
grundlegender menschlicher Fähigkeiten
das ist lächerlich
aber kennst du diesen Fake das ist so
nie gesprochen worden von Jordan
Peterson ist die das bekannt
die Frage ist wenn man Jordan Peterson
kennt ist gut wenn man die Stimme Linus
Neumann ist auch inhaltlich horchen und
ehrlich gesagt auch inhaltlich genauso
klassischer Gedankengang eigentlich von
Jordan Peterson der hat das aber nie
gesagt
was wir auffällt ist wir sitzen hier in
einer Runde von Menschen die die wir an
der Wahrheit gelegen ist ja wir haben
aber gerade ja viel darüber gesprochen
dass die ganze Menge Leute gibt denen es
gar nicht vielleicht unbedingt an der
Wahrheit gelegen ist das heißt
wenn wir doch schon in einer Welt in der
Donald Trump irgendwie geschweige Geld
Zahlungen bringen kann mit 34
Anklagepunkten vor gerichte geht und
Menschen schon daran nicht mehr glauben
aber doch potentiell schon eine
vielleicht viel schlimmere Krise als das
jetzt noch ist einfacher wird
falsche Beweise zu liefern also ich
mache mir wirklich größere Sorgen
darüber sind was was ist was das mit
einer Gesellschaft machen die auf einmal
glauben kann was sie will
und der ist auch einfach gemacht wird zu
glauben was man will und auch alles was
man sieht nicht zu glauben und Menschen
die bewusst in alternativ Realitäten
leben wollen ja
einfach anders erklären ja und das ist
also das denke ich ist hier würde das
auf eine gesunde Gesellschaft genau
stoßen dieses Phänomen der gesunde
Sorgen machen aber wir haben ja schon
ohne dass das Videos gut gefälscht
werden können eine Gesellschaft die sich
in den unterschiedliche Realitäten gibt
und politische Akteure das auch gezielt
vorantreiben ich habe muss gerade
ehrlich gesagt an unser Gespräch denken
Herr schade vor einiger Zeit waren sie
hier bei uns immer uns nach der Sendung
genau darüber unterhalten ist auch der
Grund warum wir sie noch mal heute in
dieser Sendung geholt haben zu genau
diesem Thema da sagten sie den meisten
ist nicht klar das ist hier nicht nur
darum geht ein paar falsche
Informationen zu verbreiten und es geht
auch nicht um ein paar Spinner und um
ein paar Echo kann man in denen diese
Spinner irgendwie treffen sondern sie
sagten damals so sinngemäß und das ist
mir so hängen geblieben wir reden hier
über eine neue Art von Religion
ja das hat was das hat was von Glauben
bewusst das glauben zu wollen und sich
dann zu informieren und sich die Welt so
zu erklären und ich glaube da rutscht
ein Teil der Gesellschaft ab in den USA
aber auch bei uns das ist jetzt nicht
besonders groß aber wer weiß aber aber
so groß dass man es nicht
vernachlässigen kann absolut und ich
glaube dass uns als Gesellschaft im
Moment noch ein bisschen die Instrumente
dafür fehlen dagegen zu steuern und das
hat unter anderem auch damit zu tun dass
eben Diskurse über ganz wichtige Dinge
irgendwo anders stattfinden und nicht
mehr da wo sie stattfinden sollen auch
eine Tabuisierung vielleicht von
gewissen Themen und dann dann wandern
Leute ab in diese Echokammern und da
profitieren Leute wie Trump und andere
davon und ich meine Fox News wir haben
gerade gesehen Fox News versucht da noch
zu fischen die versuchen noch diese
Leute irgendwie zu halten und damit Geld
zu verdienen aber das ist eine sehr sehr
brisante Entwicklung weil da geht's
letztendlich auch darum wie wir eine
Gesellschaft organisieren und ob wir
noch andere Dinge wie Demokratie glaube
richtig also im Grunde die alte these wo
die Ideologie da das Geschäfts generell
nicht weit Johannes hanom möchte sich
dazu noch mal einbringen Johannes bitte
ja genau ich würde gerne noch eine Ebene
Diskussion mit einbringen denn der Punkt
ist das ist gab einen ehemaligen
KGB-Offizier der in nach Amerika
übergelaufen ist in den 70er Jahren und
der hat davon gesprochen das ist das
Ziel sei das der Kommunisten in
russland-union hier im Westen die
Menschen zu desillusionieren und wie
macht man das am besten indem man das äh
dem man nur noch Lügen verbreitet und
der wird ein konservativer
intellektueller hier hat gesagt der
Moderne autoritäre Führer der braucht
nicht mehr mit Gewalt zu herrschen
sondern der führt durch Desillusion das
heißt die Leute glauben an gar nichts
mehr
rum bis gleich und niemand glaubt mir
irgendwas und dann kannst du die
Menschen kontrollieren das heißt das
ganze ist hat auch eine sehr schwere aus
meiner Sicht politische Ebene der mir
Demokratien uns stellen müssen das ist
ein Angriff auf unserer Wertesystem das
von Mächten geführt wird die unser
Wertesystem ablehnen und wir sehen dass
sie in den USA massiven Angriffe auf die
Wahlen aus China aus Russland die sind
ein großes Thema das ist eine politische
Waffe auch
es geht um die Frage wer überprüft die
Wahrheit und dieser Mechanismus den
Johannes gerade beschreibt der sehr
korrekt beschrieben ich habe überall nur
harari schreibt in den Lektion fürs 21
Jahrhundert der Sensor der Vergangenheit
hat die Leute doof gehalten indem man
sie von Informationen abgeschnitten hat
der Zensor des 21 jahrhunderts macht es
genau andersrum der Müll zieht zu bis
sie irgendwann nicht mehr wissen wo oben
und unten und links und rechts ist und
ich stehe gerade unter dem Eindruck
einer Reise nach Moldawien und auch nach
Odessa Wochenende wo mir die Leute
sagten sehr interessant dieser Krieg in
der Ukraine ist wahnsinnig gefährlich
und das ist für uns Angst einflößend und
furchteinflößend aber noch viel
gefährlicher ist die russische
Propaganda und was mich so entsetzt hat
war das bis ins letzte Detail hinein
dieselben die gleichen Argumente wie sie
hier auch kommen von Menschen die dann
zu erklären versuchen warum der arme
Putin provoziert worden ist warum da gar
kein anderer Wahl hatte als diesen Krieg
vom Zaun zu brechen bis ins letzte
kleinteilige Argument hinein und ich bin
mir sicher auch in den USA wenn man
Leute fragen würde erzählen die genau
die gleiche Geschichte das heißt das ist
eine weltumspannende Geschichte und die
Frage wie kriegen wir das in den Griff
Florian sagt wir müssten eigentlich
Maschinen haben Software haben die
sofort feststellen kann ist dieses Foto
beispielsweise ist dieses Video ist es
echt oder nicht echt aber was heißt das
da ist meine dann ja dann bist du bei
George 1984 genau das ist total
Überwachung also wer entscheidet
sozusagen über die Wahrheit die Frage ob
man Wahrheitsministerium möchte oder
eine große oder nicht eine gruselige
Vorstellung ich glaube das will
ernsthaft eigentlich niemand mit
gesundem Menschenverstand und die Frage
wenn man solche Mechanismen entwickelt
also solche Filter die schnell erkennen
dass ein Bild falsch ist oder ein Video
ist ja auch immer noch die Frage wo muss
ich denn da an also wer soll diese Dinge
denn einsetzen also sollen wir als
Medien das tun sollen das soziale
Netzwerke implementieren damit solche
Dinge gar nicht erst hochgeladen werden
aber vielleicht noch ganz kurz einen
Schritt zurück ich glaube was wir total
verkannt haben und im Blick auf die
Ukraine merkt man das natürlich dass der
Wetter Union und die sowjetischen
Geheimdienste haben das zu einer
Kunstform sterilisiert die beherrschen
das seit Jahrzehnten in einer in einer
Detailtiefe und einer Elements
Entscheidungen zu destabilisieren
anderen Gesellschaften zu erkennen das
zu verstärken man hat das ja auch
gesehen wir black lives matter Bewegung
wurde versucht zu unterwandern bei der
Präsidentschaft in den Wahlen in den USA
das war das war etwas da haben russische
Dienste agiert und die machen das in den
in den anderen Staaten ganz vehement und
dieses Modding the water hat man das in
den kalten Kriege oft genannt dieses
Wasser trüb machen so dass du gar nicht
mehr weißt so viele Lügen als man so
viele Dinge dass du gar nicht mehr weißt
was die Realität ist am Ende zweifelst
du das ganze System an oder ob eine Wahl
richtig und ehrlich und und sauber
stattgefunden hat oder oder eben nicht
in den USA ist ja das erschreckende dass
das übernommen wurde und zwar vom
Präsidenten also die Frage wer ist
eigentlich der wo sind die
einflussagenten moskauz und sich dann
die Frage zu stellen sitzt der
vielleicht im Weißen Haus und sind diese
Mechanismen nicht da übernommen worden
aus einem autoritären System heraus was
zur Bevölkerungskontrolle auch mal
geschaffen wurde der eigenen und dann
natürlich Destabilisierung der anderen
das ist wirklich sehr erschreckend dass
das mittlerweile dort sozusagen genuin
auch in den USA produziert wird es ist
ja nicht so dass es ein neues Phänomen
ist immer das können wir jetzt schon
wirklich seit vielen Jahren und das
russische Propaganda als Beispiel so
funktioniert und ähm was ich erschrecken
finde ist dass
unsere Reaktion klar wir sind eine
Demokratie die braucht auch ein bisschen
länger das finde ich auch gut also ich
würde jetzt nicht dafür plädieren dass
dass wir sozusagen auch autoritär ganz
schnell Gegenmaßnahmen müssen aber es
dauert natürlich schon sehr lange also
die Überlegung wie wie reagieren wir auf
auf Hacker wie reagieren wie auf
Desinformationen das geht bis runter
in die Frage wie wie
lernen wir das auch unseren unseren
Kindern mit Desinformationen umzugehen
ich glaube in Finnland ist das Teil des
Schulprogramms bei uns natürlich noch
nicht also diese diese Wahrnehmung da da
findet etwas statt schon seit vielen
Jahren was mit massiver
Beeinflussung Manipulation mit hacking
und so zu tun hat
und darauf müssen wir als wehrhafte
Demokratie auch wirklich hart
reagieren diese Erkenntnis setzt sich
wirklich sehr sehr langsam durch und das
ist das Problem
man sagte gerade Wahrheitsministerium so
als Gedanke ohne dass jetzt ernsthaft zu
wollen weil ihm auch klar ist was das
bedeuten kann sie sagen auf gar keinen
Fall und technologisch auch schwierig
warum die Frage wäre wo müssten wir
anfangen ja fangen wir bei den Tweets an
ja dann müsste jeder Tweet kontrolliert
werden wird vom Aufwand her Wahnsinn und
es musste sehr einfach diese Filter
müssen ja auf alles gehen ihr müsst ihr
auf jedes Bild was irgendjemand
twittert dann halt ansetzen dass das
technisch zu lösen
wäre glaube ich wirklich der endgültige
Kind mit dem Bade aus kippen weil was
wir ja haben ist eine Gesellschaft die
in einer Angst getrieben wird in eine
Unsicherheit getrieben werden soll und
in dieser Angst und dieser Unsicherheit
und dieser Verwirrung sind man sich
danach der starken Person z.B Donald
Trump jetzt würde ich auch übrigens
davon wäre ich vorsichtig zu sagen das
ist jetzt so ein Angriff von Russland
oder China sondern der jetzt irgendwie
Block geprägt ist oder so weil Donald
Trump ja gerade schon gesagt diese diese
schien ja auch sehr gut das heißt es ist
ein meisterlich meisterlich ja und das
ist also bisher noch 34 Anklagepunkte
ich glaube
geheime agentes Auslands ist doch nicht
mit dabei kommt irgendwann noch aber die
also wir werden wenn wir auch dieses
diesen Werte kann und den wir mit dem
wir uns ja gerade wieder Rüben gerade
wenn wir hier schöne Deutschland sitzt
und über die Ukraine sprechen über die
über Russland wenn wir diesen Werte kann
und in 10 Jahren noch verteidigen wollen
dann müssen die Menschen den leben
können und das da stimme ich genau mit
zu dann müssen die Menschen lernen mit
dieser neuen Herausforderung umzugehen
es wird nicht funktionieren die zu
bevormunden leider nicht oder zum Glück
nicht oder auf jeden oder vielleicht
funktioniert auch aber dann müssen wir
unsere demokratischen Werte aufgeben wir
werden gerade wir offenbaren gerade eine
Angriffsfläche die wir uns selber
eingebrockt haben weil wir
bis vor kurzem noch in der in der Schule
die Maßgabe hatten die Existenz des
Internets vor den Kindern so lange wie
möglich geheim zu halten und das
irgendwie ja es wird doch niemanden der
Umgang damit beigebracht wir finden wir
finden uns plötzlich in dieser Welt
wieder das war vor wenigen Monaten gab
es das nicht so vor wenigen Monaten gab
es was ich für die Leute sich da
angeguckt habe aber jetzt kommt auf
einmal kommt diese Dinge diese
Technologie ist auf einmal in der Welt
und wir stehen hier mit einer
Gesellschaft den keiner Weise darauf
vorbereitet wurde das ist der
strafrechtliche Versorgung und ohne
jetzt über Wahrheitsministerium zu reden
es wird ja versucht dagegen zu arbeiten
auch von entscheidender und wichtiger
Stelle also bei der EU gibt es diese
Stelle die russische Desinformation
versucht zu entlarven die Frage ist wie
viele Menschen diese Webseite kennen und
irgendwie da drauf klicken ähm und wenn
es dann doch in ihrem facebook oder
twitter feed erscheint wie sie
eigentlich damit umgehen aber es gibt
ganz praktisches Beispiel zu Beginn des
Krieges gegen die Ukraine taucht ein
Video auf was Nordrhein-Westfalen in dem
eine Frau behauptet hat einen da sei ein
junger Russe tot geprügelt worden in
Nordrhein-Westfalen da die Polizei
extrem schnell reagiert und gesagt ein
solches Tötungsdelikt ist dort nicht
bekannt und damit sollte offenbar diese
rusophobestimmung angeheizt werden das
war schnell das war gut man hat das
versucht zu entlarven man ist da schnell
hinterher ich frage mich was machen wir
eigentlich und davor davor muss man
glaube ich echt Angst haben bis zum
gewissen Grad und das wird auch kommen
was ist wenn es dazu noch ein Video gäbe
was das irgendwie zeigt also eine
Fälschung die das noch mal richtig und
dann kommen wir auf einer Ebene ganz
lokale Ebene war eine Frau das behauptet
bei mir in der Kleinstadt ist das
passiert und ich sag mal so Herr
Klitschko kann das noch relativ schnell
ausräumen dass er das war aber was mache
ich denn bei solchen Straftaten die dann
so wirken und die sich dann verbreiten
und da liegt glaube ich ihn immer oder
wenn jemand wie selenski plötzlich die
Kapitulation ankündigt auch das hat
stattgefunden wir hören einmal kurz rein
auch das eine Aussage ein Video eine
Situation die es so nie gegeben hat
und jetzt muss ich eine weitere schwer e
Entscheidung treffen
ich muss mich von euch verabschieden
und ich rate euch die Waffen
niederzulegen und zu euren Familien
zurückzugeben
dieser Krieg ist das nicht wert in ihm
zu sterben
ich rate euch zu leben ich werde
dasselbe tun
ich meine ich muss es ja gar nicht
selber gesehen haben es ist ja noch viel
wirkmächtiger wenn wir jemanden Flade
erzählt das gibt es und ich erzähl's
dann schlicht und ergreifend weiter oder
ich höre nur die Stimme ähnlich wie bei
Jordan Peterson vorhin das Video ist
relativ schlecht wir haben gerade gehört
in zwei drei vier fünf Jahren bitte so
perfekt sein dass man sich mal
unterscheiden kann aber die Stimmen sind
heute schon so gut also dass das nicht
Jordan Peterson ist hätte ich nicht
gehört ehrlich gesagt ja Johannes Hanau
will sich die ganze Zeit einbringen wir
haben noch nie eine eine offene
Diskussion über den Umweg geführt macht
eine große Freude muss ich sagen und und
so munter das auch zu tun das ist ein
großer Spaß Johannes deine Antwort
gleich auf das was du sagen wolltest und
vor allen Dingen auch die Frage noch mal
Elon Musk der ja sehr viel investiert
glaube ich auch in in Startups
künstliche Intelligenz und so weiter und
der schon vor Jahren immer wieder sagte
wir müssen da aufpassen dass wir wir uns
nicht etwas ans Bein binden was wir
irgendwann nicht mehr kontrollieren
können
es gibt ja auch Bücher die sagen
künstliche Intelligenz da unsere letzte
menschliche Entwicklung gewesen die wird
uns überholen ja das ist eine das ist
eine wichtige Diskussion aber ich wollte
noch mal ganz kurz darauf zurückkommen
auf die Punkte wer glaubt denn
eigentlich noch irgendetwas man kann das
hier in den USA ganz genau sehen woran
das liegt hier in New York zum Beispiel
wo die Menschen überdurchschnittlich gut
gebildet sind funktioniert
Desinformation so gut wie gar nicht es
gibt natürlich hier und da mal
irgendetwas aber im Grunde genommen ist
Bildung das ganz zentrale Element und
man sieht das dass es vor allen Dingen
in den sogenannten fly over States in
den Communitys in den ländlichen
Gemeinden eine ganz einfache also da
dort verfangen diese Lügen ganz einfach
und das hängt ganz klar mit Bildung
zusammen ob ich in der Lage bin mich zu
informieren und zwar nicht nur aus einer
Quelle zur informieren ob ich in der
Lage bin kritisch zu denken und da
glaube ich müssen wir ansetzen ich
glaube nicht dass wir Leute mit Verboten
kommen können dass wir sie bevormunden
dürfen sondern wir müssen Leute so
selbstbewussten Individuum verhelfen
also dass sie selbstbewusst Entscheidung
treffen können das ist glaube ich das
Arno kommt wieder der gesunde
Menschenverstand ins Spiel ich
erlebe im Alltag das auch Menschen die
ich für überdurchschnittlich schlau und
begabt halte das auch nie mehr mit
Informationen kommen ich denke ah okay
wenn der das glaubt dann haben wir ein
Problem
erleben Sie auch so erleben Sie auch so
ja also dass das passiert gewisse Dinge
verfestigen sich irgendwie dieser Spruch
irgendwas bleibt immer hängen das stimmt
schon zu gewissen Teilen wenn man sich
das Video von selenski anguckt muss man
natürlich auch sagen wenn es gerichtet
waren die Ukraine dann hat das nicht
funktioniert weil dieses Land extrem
viel Erfahrung damit hat und ich habe
letztes Jahr mal diesen den Spruch
gehört die in der Ukraine weiß man das
natürlich die können denken wie die
Sowjets in Kämpfen wie die Nato und das
macht sie natürlich irgendwie
erfolgreich und deswegen sind sie auch
resilienter als Gesellschaft das
Baltikum übrigens auch die beschäftigen
sich lange damit und diese Länder werden
Vergewaltigung wenn alles mögliche genau
und die wissen dass ihr Präsident nicht
sagt gibt es auch oder so ja also dass
das geht noch auf der Ebene wie gesagt
wir machen eher diese kleine Rennen
Geschichten Sorge die man dann
vielleicht nicht mehr so schnell
entlarven kann weil die Person nicht so
prominent ist und nicht sofort melden
kann die Menschheit muss jetzt lernen
mit dem Verlust Gesicher ter Wahrheiten
zu Leben
interessanter Satz
ich sehe keinen anderen Ausweg ja also
ich fände es ja auch schön weil also ist
auch naheliegender Gedanke zu sagen hier
ist eine Technologie die schafft uns ein
Problem kann nicht die gleiche
Technologie das Problem auch wieder
lösen ja also können wir nicht wenn wir
KI sagen können fälschen Bild kann man
nicht KI trainieren gefälschte Bilder zu
erkennen Problem gelöst ja aber das ich
glaube wir haben hier ist am Ende eher
mit einem gesellschaftlichen Phänomen
als mit einem technischen zu tun und ich
glaube dass wir mit diesen
Unsicherheiten leben müssen das gerade
auch gesagt wurde selbstbewusste mündige
Individuen auf diesem Modell auf diesen
Menschenbild und diese Modell baut unser
System auf unserer Gesellschaftssystem
und ich fürchte das haben wir zu lange
wirklich gerade auch in Deutschland
nicht gepflegt ist einfach nicht
gepflegt dass wir dass wir in einem
x-gliedrigen Bildungssystem Leuten sagen
ja passt du brauchst gar kein
Politikunterricht oder oder solche Dinge
das ist ganz ganz fürchterlich dass das
Bildungssystem nicht darauf ausgerichtet
ist Menschen zu ermündigen zu mündigen
Menschen zu machen wenn man dann
irgendwann dann findet man sich auf
einmal wieder und sagt oh jetzt ist das
Problem zu groß versuchen was jetzt mal
ihr wie zentral zu regeln Ja und das
wird also muss ja nicht lange zu
erzählen was passiert wenn diese Systeme
dann in die Hände der falschen Leute
gerade der falschen Leute geraten und
dann haben wir das dann haben wir das
also solche
Kontrollmöglichkeiten dürfen nicht
schaffen also bleibt uns nur die Flucht
in die in die in die Resilienz